I work this blaze near Big Timber
Montana and the blink of an eye just
fire everywhere and then charging out of
these clients comes this bear on fire
was the most beautiful and terrible
thing I've ever seen
I heard you guys had some slots
available are you doing here I just had
a daughter and I just really want to
give her what I never had if you give me
a chance I won't let you down
you know the difference between tattoo
crew and hotshots yes sir hotshots are
on the front line and they get to engage
the fire directly you guys are tied to
so why don't you do what you do best
stay in the back and mop up our [ __ ]
no one's like honey you undo your jello
morning game
[Music]
in training for over four years got all
our hours all our qualifications sooner
or later
fire is going to come knock it in our
hometown but until we're certified my
crew won't even be able to set foot on
the line doing something that's never
been done before it takes time
it's not easy sharing a man with
until debris then this beautiful Vista
because once you're hot jobs you're
never gonna be able to look out in the
world see that pure beauty of you the
fire gets past our line it goes to our
town no matter what you hear what's
going on we can't go back up there stand
together
look out for each other because you're a
family
no one could be prouder of his boys than
I am of you guys
[Music]
[Music]